e
e e
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn represent Osborne
moves let the member from represent
Osborne's not
chair recognizes representative Bogard
who moves the house adjourned from the
session of January 8th
2025 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those say nay the
eyes have it the house is adjourned the
house will attend to requests for leaves
of
absence Mr Speaker the day important
business Representatives Aldridge Alward
Balon Baldwin Barton bman beler B Bixby
Bolton buard buo Colby ktoa Crawford
Dary DD Pand Tom Dolan Drew Dupont
Durkin Edgar fauler Foss Lauren Fox gagy
Nicholas drana Gibbs Gilman Gilmore
Gonzalez gzowski Harvey Hicks Horgan
Molly Howard Jacobs Jones jurus Thomas
kazinski S Kinski kuger kofalt lalis
Lehman l l Lucas lny John McDonald maor
Malloy Manion mcer McFarlin McGrath mle
Muse Lawrence Miner Mooney Mirad Michael
Murphy Nancy Murphy Alexandre Murray Ray
Newman Sue Newman James Nome Palmer
Pressa PR rockmore rung sarin D Shri
Sergeant Shear self selig marjerie Smith
Snodgrass Sorenson Southworth G spear
Swanson scitec Taylor Thaxton Tierney
toner tutor verville Wade Walker Warden
and
woods these leaves of absent shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house the house will attend to the
introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Steve
and Cole April guests of Representative
Doug Thomas Sebastian Fuentes guest of
Representative Baldwin Claire fidal wife
of Representative fedolfi Susan Aon wife
of represent ative aan Linda Hunt wife
of Representative hunt Kate Day and The
Honorable Jane Johnson former member
from Swansea guests of Representative
roads Bob Stevens Laura Bull and The
Honorable Deb Hobson former member from
East Kingston guest of Representative
Melvin Laura Dodge guest of
Representative bolo The Honorable
Michael York guest of Representative
Simpson Eric jrom and Mrs John Dodge
guests of Representative duet The
Honorable Joe Shapiro former member from
keen and Nikki demoras guests of
Representative Dylan gerana The
Honorable Cindy warmington former
executive counselor guests of
Representative walner Luis Spencer mayor
Byron Champlin and The Honorable Colin
van aern uh former executive counselor
guests of Representative luno Charles
Lao and Alex hang of the taipe economic
and cultural office in Boston guests of
the speaker they are with us in the
gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend to a resolution Mr
Speaker Representatives Sweeney and luno
offer the following resolved that the
House of Representatives notify the
honorable Senate that it is ready to
meet in joint convention for the
purposes of hearing the report of the
governor excuse me of the Joint
Committee appointed to compare and count
the votes for governor and executive
counsel and for the inauguration of the
governor and for taking of The Oath by
the executive
counsel are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos nay
the eyes haven't the resolution is
adopted
for
e e
do
chair recognizes the clerk Mr speaker
the Senate is now ready to meet with the
House of Representatives in joint
convention for the purpose of hearing
the report of The Joint Committee
appointed to compare and count the votes
for governor and executive councel the
inauguration of the governor The
Honorable Kelly aot and the taking of
The Oath by the executive
counsel chair recognizes the Sergeant at
Arms
Mr Speaker The Honorable Senate
[Applause]
[Music]
right
there Mr Speaker president of of the
Senate The Honorable Sharon Carson of
[Applause]
londondary the joint convention will
come to order
The Joint convention will be attentive
to a report from The Joint Committee on
vote counts for governor and executive
councel Mr Speaker Representative Steven
Smith duet and Simpson and senators bsel
and Perkins qu quoka uh offer the
following report The Joint Committee
appointed to compare and count the votes
for governor executive Council reports
that it has been attended to its duties
and the vote is
correct e
ple please remain seated while our
special guests are introduced and led to
their seats the chair recognizes the
house
clerk Mr Speaker guests family and
friends of the governor elect and the
executive counselors elect
second
e
for e
don't take it out
Mr Speaker Commissioners and department
heads for the State of New
Hampshire
[Applause]
e
[Music]
for e
Mr Speaker representing New Hampshire
County Law Enforcement bellnap County
Sheriff Bill Wright and Coos County
Sheriff Keith robers
[Music]
Mr Speaker representing New Hampshire
state law enforcement the Attorney
General John formella
[Applause]
[Music]
and Colonel Mark Hall of the New
Hampshire State
[Music]
Police Mr Speaker the administrative
judge of the New Hampshire Circuit Court
The Honorable Ellen V
[Applause]
[Music]
Christo Mr Speaker the chief Chief
Justice of the New Hampshire Superior
Court The Honorable Mark E
[Applause]
Howard Mr Speaker the associate Justice
of the New Hampshire Supreme Court The
Honorable Melissa countway
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker associate Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court The Honorable
Patrick e Donovan
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker the senior associate Justice
of the New Hampshire Supreme Court the
honorable James P
[Applause]
[Music]
Basset Mr Speaker the Chief Justice of
the New Hampshire Supreme Court The
Honorable Gordon J McDonald
[Applause]
Mr Speaker from the US District Court
for the State of New Hampshire judge
Samantha D Elliott
[Applause]
Mr Speaker from the US District Court
for the State of New Hampshire judge
Joseph n La
[Applause]
plant Mr Speaker from the US District
Court for the State of New Hampshire
chief judge landia B
[Applause]
mccaffery Mr Speaker the mayor of
Manchester The Honorable Jay ruay
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the leadership of the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker former speaker of the New
Hampshire house The Honorable William L
O'Brien
[Applause]
Mr Speaker former executive counselor
The Honorable Earl
[Applause]
[Music]
Rinker please be seated
Mr Speaker former United States
ambassador to New Zealand and Samoa The
Honorable Scott
[Applause]
Brown Mr Speaker former New Hampshire
Congress The Honorable Charles F
[Applause]
bass Mr Speaker United States Senator
Margaret Wood Hassen
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker the family representing
former Governor meldam Thompson Rob Tom
and Sheila
Thompson Mr Speaker the family
representing former Governor Steven
Merill Heather
[Applause]
Merill Mr
Speaker former Governor Craig R Benson
and Denise Benson
[Applause]
Mr Speaker for the last time his
Excellency the governor Christopher
tsunu
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker the New Hampshire State
Treasurer The Honorable Monica
[Applause]
mipel Mr Speaker New Hampshire Secretary
of State The Honorable David M scanlin
[Applause]
have them
s Mr Speaker the Reverend clergy
[Applause]
Mr Speaker executive counselor
representing District 1 The Honorable
Joseph D
[Applause]
[Music]
Kenny Mr Speaker executive counselor
elect representing District 2 The
Honorable Karen Leo
[Applause]
Hill Mr Speaker the executive Council
representing District 3 The Honorable
Janet Stevens
[Music]
Mr Speaker the executive councelor elect
representing District 4 The Honorable
John
[Applause]
Steven Mr Speaker the executive
counselor representing District 5 The
Honorable David K wheeler
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the children of
governor-elect Kelly
aot by the way dude
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker escorted by Major General
David melides the ad General
governor-elect Kelly aot and Colonel
Joseph Daly
[Applause]
[Music]
The Joint convention will please please
stand and be reverently attentive while
the invocation is offered by Reverend ju
Senor Richard Kelly and Reverend David
Harris we bow our heads in a spirit of
Silent
prayer Almighty and eternal God we give
you thanks for the privilege of being
here today
in a spirit of happiness and
gratitude we ask your blessings upon our
new governor Kelly
aot we pray that she and her Min and her
Administration do what is right and just
for the people of New
Hampshire a state small in size but rich
in strength and
character may she encourage due respect
for virtue and religion
may she carry out our laws with Justice
and
mercy may she seek to restrain crime
Vice and
immorality we pray that through your
powerful protection oh
Lord that she can lead our state with
honesty and
integrity may she realize that she is
never really
alone but that she could always always
turn to you oh God to be her refuge and
strength during the good times and
challenging times that lie
ahead we thank you oh lord for her
predecessor Governor Chris sonunu and
his
administration may the Lord continue to
bless him and his
family bless Governor aot's husband
Joseph her children
family
members and many who are many many
friends and we pray all of this to you
who are our Lord God forever and ever
amen if you would continue to join me in
prayer Almighty and ever loving God you
have revealed your glory to the Nations
and have called us to be faithful
stewards of your creation we praise you
for your goodness and mercy and for
sharing with us your countless gifts we
pray for governor aot for our
legislators for judges and all public
officials who have been entrusted with
leading protecting and serving the
people of this state may they fulfill
their solemn Oaths with Integrity in a
steadfast pursuit of the common good
help us to enact laws founded upon truth
charity and Justice may we always uphold
the fundamental and intrinsic dignity
that belongs to every human
person especially for the weakest and
the most vulnerable Among Us Inspire us
to exercise our rights and freedoms to
pursue what is good and in harmony with
your Divine
Providence Empower us to be bearers of
your mercy and healing
especially to those whose lives have
been wounded by violence neglect and
hatred protect us from all evil and
strengthen those who have been called to
preserve our Safety and Security with
wisdom and
courage and after enjoying the blessings
of this life may we be admitted to those
which are
Everlasting we make this prayer in
Jesus's name amen amen thank you
the members of The Joint convention
please remain standing while posting of
the Colors by the New Hampshire National
Guard
the Pledge of Allegiance by Natalie
Healey of exitor will now lead us in the
Pledge of
Allegiance flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liy and justice for
all please remain standing while Officer
Taylor Warren of the Manchester Police
Department sings our national
[Music]
anthem by the dawn
what so
proudly we
H at the
Twilight
last
Stripes Bright
[Music]
Stars
the or the ramp parts
we were soing
[Music]
in the Rock
redare the boms
bur Pro through the
night that our flag
[Music]
was
starled
W or the
land of the
free in the
home of the brave
[Applause]
please be
seated I would not to Li I would like to
now invite the children of Governor Le
to the rostom
The Honorable Gordon J McDonald Chief
Justice of the New Hampshire Supreme
Court when all administered the oath of
office to the governor elect Aon
a
I I Kelly aot of of NASA New Hampshire
do solemnly swear do solemnly swear that
I will bear faith and true allegiance
that I will bear faith and true
allegiance to the United States of
America to the United States of America
and the state of New Hampshire and the
State of New Hampshire and will support
the Constitution and will support the
Constitution thereof thereof so help me
God so help me God I I Kelly aat do Som
solemnly and
sincerely solemnly and sincerely swear
and affirm swear and affirm that I will
faithfully and impartially that I will
faithfully and impartially discharge and
perform discharge and perform all the
duties incumbent on me all the duties
incumbent upon me as as Governor
according to the best of my abilities
agreeably to the rules and
regulations agreeably to the rules and
regulations of this constitution of this
Constitution and laws of the State of
New Hampshire and laws of the State of
New Hampshire so help me God so help me
God congratulations govern
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations Governor thanks Governor
rat will now administer the oath of
office to The Honorable executive
counselors please raise your right hand
and where appropriate state your
name and where you live
I
of do solemnly swear that I will bear
faith and true
Allegiance II and Al to the United
States of America and the state of New
Hampshire to the United States of
America
stsh and will support the Constitutions
thereof so help me God and will support
the Constitutions thereof
I state your name do solemnly and
sincerely
swear and affirm that I will faithfully
and
impartially discharge and perform all
the duties incumbent upon me as an
executive counselor
according to the best of my
abilities agreeably to the rules and
regulations rules and regulations of
this Constitution and the laws of the
State of New
Hampshire so help me God
[Applause]
congratulations The Joint convention
will be attentative to the inaugural
address by Governor Kelly
aart Mr Speaker Madame President Mr
chief justice honorable members of the
house senate counselors former governors
my fellow
citizens it is humbling to stand before
you
today it is so wonderful for me to be
able to see so many of my family who are
here for this moment and I especially
want to thank my parents for everything
that they have done for
me in this chamber I see friends
colleagues and dedicated public
servants but what's more I see the
passion energy and
Independence that makes our state
different that drives a common sense
approach to governing that has made this
the best state in the
nation we are number one for Freedom
we're number one for opportunity for
taxpayer return on investment Public
Safety and child
well-being and we have the lowest tax
burden in the nation and the lowest
poverty rate in the
[Applause]
nation and I'm going to need another
round of applause because New Hampshire
is moving in the right
direction because there's no one that
deserves more credit for that than his
four terms at the home than Governor
Chris cunu Governor thank you
[Applause]
Governor I want to thank you I want to
thank Valerie I want to thank your
children for your dedicated service to
our
state there's a lot of people I'm
thankful for today I'm also thankful to
have my former boss uh and also my close
friend Governor Craig Benson here he saw
potential in me at a young age and
provided me the opportunity to serve as
attorney
general but unfortunately today there is
someone important who's not here we're
missing our great friend mentor and the
chairman of my first two campaigns
Governor Steve Merill and I'm so proud
that his wife Heather Merill is here
with us today thank you so much Heather
for being here means a
lot I think we both know that Steve is
looking down and smiling right
now over the past year we've lost some
incredible public servants in our state
two women that I've always respected and
looked up to Ruth Griffin and Nancy cunu
I'm thinking of them both
today but there's one person I can tell
you I wouldn't be here if it weren't for
him there is no way I would be here if
it weren't for my wingman Joe
[Music]
and we all have Joe by the way I have
Joe to thank for all the great recipe
suggestions I got on the campaign
trail and I just it's my moment to set
the record straight he snores way louder
than me I'm just
saying all kidding aside our family
story like many of yours is a story of
service Joe is a former air Air Force
A10 pilot he's now a middle school math
teacher our daughter Kate is a Cadet at
the United States Air Force Academy and
our son
[Music]
our son Jake enjoys volunteering at our
local food
pantry I've spent my life in thanks
Jak I've spent my life in public service
first as a murder prosecutor later as
attorney general US
senator but today today is the honor of
a life as your next governor
service can take on so many
forms and all of us wouldn't be here
today all of you wouldn't be here today
if you weren't dedicated to serving our
citizen legislature is a model for the
nation and I want to thank each and
every one of you for your dedicated
service to our state
[Music]
we cannot forget that service takes
teaching it takes
demonstrating and if we don't teach our
kids we they aren't going to learn it it
is so important that we root our lives
in something bigger than ourselves and
it is critical for the health of our
state and our communities that our next
Generation step up and contribute so so
one of the things I am looking forward
to the most as Governor is when those
fourth graders uh they come to the state
house and I get to speak with them and I
want to talk to them about how service
feels what it feels to help others to be
part of something larger than yourself I
want them to know that there are as many
ways to serve as you can imagine and
that the Fulfillment that you can can
receive from giving all that you can to
help others that's how Joe and I raised
our kids and that is what I will have in
my heart as your
[Applause]
Governor speaker
Packard president
Carson I look forward to working with
both of you
I'm looking for both of you to Marshal
our strong Republican majorities to
deliver on the promises that we made to
keep our state moving in the right
direction
[Music]
the results these past several years
speak for themselves but we have more to
do to deliver for
everyone the corner office is the
people's office it's not about me it's
about our state and all of us together
you have my word that each and every day
I will work on your behalf to do what's
best for all of us for all of New
Hampshire I'm going to be a governor for
you whether you're a republican a
Democrat an independent you name it
because our state is so much bigger than
a party or an
ideology minority leaders Perkins quoka
and Simpson I want you to know that my
door is always open good government
knows no party so let's show the folks
that when partisanship is at a fever
pitch we can set a different example
[Music]
[Applause]
I know you heard me talk a lot on the
campaign Trail about
Massachusetts and the reason I did is
because it's a cautionary
tale look at the out ofc control
spending tax hikes illegal immigrant
crisis people and businesses leaving in
droves but what's normal today in
Massachusetts it wasn't always that way
year after year their model of higher
taxes and more government has made it
harder for small businesses to make and
families to make ends
meet on the other hand over that same
period New Hampshire has gotten stronger
but only because of our leadership our
policies and our commitment to
taxpayers to the people of
Massachusetts our Bay State neighbors I
want you to know we love that you visit
our communities shop at our businesses
enjoy our Great Outdoors to the
businesses of Massachusetts we'd love to
have you bring your talents to the
Granite
[Applause]
State we're happy to show you why it's
better here and to our friends over our
northern border in Canada the same goes
for you we'll welcome your business with
open arms to the Granite State and
especially to our North Country and your
bottom line will benefit if you come
here as Governor I will work tirelessly
to recruit businesses to our state from
near and far I will doggedly pursue
opportunities for economic expansion and
I will bring businesses to the table to
ensure that Economic Opportunity is is
available for
everyone because I think we can all
agree that New Hampshire is truly a
special
place and I believe that our spirit of
Common Sense cooperation is part of what
makes that true we have Extraordinary
People abilities ideas and passions and
an independence that no other state
embodies like we do
[Music]
and we're tough some say it's the
weather others say it's the granite I
say it's our Live Free or Die
Spirit I'm focused on tapping our deep
well of talent at so that our government
has the best the best people and the
best
ideas I made it a point during this
transition I to bring people from
outside of government to sit with me and
to give me perspective on how things are
going I've been glad to have Business
Leaders sit with me as we meet with
Commissioners to see where things are so
that we can look for new ideas about
where things should go next when you've
got as many accolades as this state has
it would be easy for us to rest on our
successes and not strive forward with
the same energy
but nothing helps battle complacency
more than bringing new people into the
fold from my time in the private sector
these past number of years I saw
firsthand the benefit of challenging the
status quo of and bringing New Blood to
it so we're going to make sure that we
have new people new ideas and new energy
to get the job done for the people of
New Hampshire
[Music]
[Applause]
and if we're going to keep our our state
on the path of
prosperity if we are going to deliver
for all of New Hampshire we have to
bring everyone to the
table from the corner office to the
legislature to the executive counsel to
the private sector to nonprofit profits
and we've got to get to work immediately
because while things are great today
tomorrow holds real challenges for our
state if we're going to remain the
economic Beacon of New England that we
are we need to start by tackling our
housing
crisis this is about now and it's about
our
future our state has so much opportunity
to offer but our lack of of housing
Supply and sky high costs are making it
increasingly difficult for individuals
to tap into it it affects everyone from
the young family looking to buy their
first home to the business that's trying
to hire more workers to the retiree who
wants to stay in their home and
selfishly as the mom of a 20-year-old
and a teenager um you know I want them
to stay here but our young people aren't
going to stay here if they can't afford
to we need to get serious about housing
production we need to streamline agency
approvals and we need to partner with
our local
communities the Journey of a Thousand
Steps begins with the first one and
there isn't a simple solution to this
crisis so we will pursue an all the
above
strategy we have to bring everyone to
the table the state the local community
the private sector so we can figure out
where the opportunities are and how we
can be clear to build and strengthen new
and existing
Partnerships a great example of this is
happening in Rochester under mayor pal
Paul Callahan this fall I had the chance
to join the mayor at a ground breaking
at Rapids at Kono project a 52 unit
Workforce housing project that came to
together because the city stepped up HUD
was there the private sector New
Hampshire Housing and state government
all working together or look at Berlin
where the old Brown Elementary School it
was repurposed for new housing we need
to look at State Property like this and
find Opportunities to leverage
underutilized assets on our books and
make sure that they are using their in
their highest and best
use as a state we need to model good
behavior if we're going to ask the same
of our local communities who make these
zoning
decisions that starts with overhauling
the agency process to make sure that it
takes no more than 60 days to get
approval for a project
[Music]
[Applause]
the bottom line is we need to make the
process as frictionless as possible so
projects that are great for our
communities are not getting halted by
unnecessary red
tape working together we can tackle this
housing crisis headon and make sure that
New Hampshire Remains the best place to
live
[Music]
well being Governor is certainly a big
job I can tell you the biggest job that
I've had in my life and I know Joe
agrees is that of being a
parent as a parent our life's work is
our children we pour into them in so
many ways when they're under our roofs
and when they leave they're never far
from our
hearts as public servants we must bring
that spirit and focus to our education
system we are in the top 10 in total
education funding per pupil in the
country I think that's wonderful and we
need to keep it up but it's not only
about dollars and cents it's also about
how best do our children learn and what
kind of environment are we creating in
our
classrooms as a mother I understand that
every child learns differently and we
should give each child the opportunity
to be in the education setting that
allows them to reach their full
potential as an individual
[Music]
[Applause]
public schools are
critical I am the proud product of NASA
public schools and so is
Joe but it's not working for every child
I applaud the work the legislature has
done to expand opportunities for
families through education Freedom
accounts and I look
[Music]
forward and we're going to work and I
look forward to working with all of you
on strengthening and expanding the
program to ensure that more families
have the freedom to put their children
in the learning environment that is best
for them to reach their full
[Applause]
potential Joe and I talk all the time
about what he sees in the
classroom uh with his students
and he and the thousands of teachers in
our state they're on the front lines of
our education system teachers know
uniquely what's working for our students
and we need to listen to them that's why
today I'm announcing that we will be
taking action to ban cell phones in our
classrooms
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry there is more
when it comes to our kids one of the
things that we need to make sure that we
aren't doing and unfortunately it has
happened is that sometimes in our
schools we haven't had the hard
conversations that we need to have when
it comes to where our children are and
how prepared they are for the next step
these hard conversations are very very
important so that we aren't passing
children along when they aren't prepared
to go on to their career or on to their
next studies this is
critical we also need to expand in our
state uh Career Technical education this
is so critical
[Applause]
we need to
expand uh the existing public private
Partnerships that are already in place
we need to make sure that we expand the
pipeline at our community colleges that
are in place how important it is and
what is happening we we need that our
young people to understand that there
are so many amazing jobs that are open
in our trades and that those jobs need
to be filled if we want to build all
this housing if we want to get things
done in this state uh and these are
great paying jobs and we need to keep
telling the Amazing Stories of the
opportunities that exist in the trades
and the more and more Pathways to and
create more Pathways to a good paying
career we need to work together on this
this is an issue for all of
us so one of the things I'm really proud
of about New Hampshire is that our state
stands as a model for the rest of the
country when it comes to living within
our means and balancing our
budgets can you imagine if Washington
took a page out of our
[Applause]
Playbook I'm even prouder that we do it
with no income tax no sales tax with our
New Hampshire
advantage and taxpayers now are keeping
more money in their pockets due to the
elimination of the interest in dividends
tax
[Music]
and by the way I'm I'm not going to
surprise anyone when I say no income tax
no sales tax not now not
[Music]
ever and I would also say to our local
officials don't don't forget the
importance of keeping the tax burden as
low as possible property taxes are a
burden in New Hampshire in spite of the
fact that the state is sending more
money than ever before down to the local
level but while we have a lot to be
proud of when it comes to financial
restraint challenges are ahead of us in
the coming
budget the large amount of federal
funding from the American Rescue plan is
expired
iring business revenues are coming in
lower than the past several
years and that means we have gotten to
tight we've got to tighten our belt here
in
conquer and just like any
family what's going out has to match
what's coming in so we are going to have
to make reductions and re-calibrate from
the higher spending over the last
several years
[Music]
we are going to have to look for better
ways to do things with less
money now whenever we talk about Cuts
just like a family making hard decisions
there's things that we cannot skimp on
protecting our most vulnerable and those
in our state most in need
like this is
non-negotiable like groceries and gas
for
families this is
important but we do have to carefully
look across our budgets of every agency
and find savings to deal with the
financial realities that we
Face I've instructed our commissioners
to roll up their sleeves and find ways
to rethink our approach and where
appropriate do more with less we need to
make sure that government is operating
more like the lean process in
manufacturing where waste is eliminated
each step in the process for a better
result and to help us do this because I
know there is nothing harder than
politicians and asking them not to spend
money um so today I'm announcing the
creation of the commission on government
efficiency or as I like to call
[Music]
it I like to call it the
cach um what can I say uh the Cod will
make us smarter than ever before when it
comes to saving taxpayer dollars and
finding better ways to serve the people
of this state and I can think of no
better Duo to lead this effort than two
of the smartest business guys I know
Governor Craig Benson and Andy
[Music]
Cruz they're going to put proposals on
my desk to streamline government cut
spending and ensure that we're doing
everything we can to create value for
taxpayers as a former Attorney
General it's not going to come any
surprise to any of you that my top
priority is going to be keeping our
state safe and that I will always have
the backs of our law enforcement
officers and our First
[Music]
Responders I want to thank all of our
law enforcement officers who are here
today but if we're going to keep New
Hampshire the safest state in the nation
we need to make critical investments in
our group two retirement system to make
sure we retain and
recruit if we do not make these critical
Investments we will not be able to
recruit and retain the people that work
in our communities on nights weekends
and holidays to make sure that all of us
can enjoy our quality of life
[Applause]
[Music]
we also need to ban Sanctuary policies
in our state
[Applause]
and I'm counting on our legislature to
do that this term
we've got Massachusetts illegal
immigrant crisis right down the road and
if you want to see what these dangerous
policies do not just to communities but
to a
budget they've spent a billion dollars
housing migrants rather than spending it
investing it on their law-abiding
citizens we cannot allow that to happen
here in New Hampshire
[Music]
we're also not done on bail reform I
firmly believe the legislature did more
harm than good when they changed our
bail law and the recent reforms just
don't go far
enough listen I think many of you heard
me talk about this but I did a ride
along with the Manchester police
department and it really stuck with me
uh this young officer I was with he lost
six months of work because he had his
pinky noded to the Bone by someone who
was out on bail that should not have
been I want to thank mayor Rue because
he has worked really hard to turn the
tide in Manchester but we need to get
this law fixed so that we can keep all
of our communities
protected thank
[Music]
and the other issue that we need to work
on to improve our quality of life is our
mental health
system our mental health system is so
important to strengthening our
communities and providing the F families
the assistance they need from loved ones
I heard so much about these types of
stories of people seeking help as I
traveled around the
state and throughout New Hampshire I've
heard about the urgent need that we need
more Mental Health Providers there are
not enough providers and we are going to
look for ways working with our community
college system and our University system
to expand educational opportunities for
our Mental Health
Providers a few months ago I had the
opportunity along with Governor sen cunu
and mayor Ru to visit hope for New
Hampshire recovery in Manchester they're
working hard to help those recovering
from substance use
disorder they share with me that many of
their clients are battling addiction and
mental health challenges at the same
time but licensing for new providers
presented them a challenge when trying
to grow their
team all too often
substance use treatment and Mental
Health Care are siloed when it would be
better for us to address these
challenges today to treat the whole
individual in addition to strengthening
the system itself we also need to ensure
that anyone who is facing a mental
health challenge feels that they can
reach out for help and that they can
come forward seeking help for your
mental health is just as important as
when we see a doctor when you're feeling
sick or you have a physical
injury we all need to work together and
take care of each other together we can
Elevate the importance of mental health
awareness and suicide prevention efforts
throughout this state
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a few groups near and dear to
my heart you've heard about law
enforcement but there's another group
that's even nearer and dearer to my
heart and that's those who have served
in our Armed
Forces could I have all the veterans and
those who have served stand up in the
room today
[Applause]
[Music]
please thank you from the bottom of my
heart I want each of you to know and I
want every veteran in our state to know
that they will have a friend in my
Administration we're going to fight for
you we're going to help you if you need
anything I want to hear from you get in
touch with us we will bolster the New
Hampshire Department of military and
veteran services in their efforts to
advocate for
veterans I also know that incredibly
important work also happens with our
nonprofits nonprofits like swim with a
mission Easter Seals veterans count and
so many others working together with our
robust nonprofit community and with
state and local leaders we will make
sure that New Hampshire is the most
veteran friendly state in the country
[Applause]
the greatest resource our state
has besides its
people is our beautiful
landscape no other state boasts the
natural beauty we do and there's a lot
that comes with that from Recreation to
tourism to Industry
and a true Gem of our state is our North
Country we need to make sure that it
stays that
way my Administration is going to
enforce the state's conservation
easement on the Connecticut Headwaters
tract that was negotiated on a
bipartisan basis with then Governor Jean
Shaheen and Senator jug Greg and we're
going to ensure that that beautiful
track of land remains open for
recreation and that it also remains open
for logging and Timber harvesting for
the people of New
[Music]
Hampshire similarly
there will be no
landfill at Forest Lake in
[Applause]
Dalton we will not allow that beautiful
part of our state and that beautiful
area to become a Dumping Ground for aate
trash it's just not going to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
lastly before I
close and just in case you forgot
because I know it's been a few months
since there haven't been all those ads
on the on the
TV but if you send me legislation that
further restricts access to abortion
beyond our current law I will veto it
[Music]
[Applause]
New Hampshire is a beautiful wonderful
State you know Joe and I were both born
here we love this State and I just want
to thank you for the privilege of a
lifetime of serving as your next
governor and protecting what makes us
unique it's so much more important than
one person or one
party I want you to know that I will be
a governor for everyone and please know
this even when we don't see eye to eye I
will always look to bring us
together I I could not be more
optimistic about our
future but at the same time we have real
challenges that we have to take headon
if we want to keep our state moving in
the right
direction voters are expecting us to
find better
ways to make sure that we strengthen
this great state that we grow our
economy and we increase our quality of
life
we need to be proactive in securing new
victories that will make our community
safer our families more prosperous and
our daily lives more
free I look forward to working with all
of you who are here today and everyone
in the state of New Hampshire to deliver
that for the greatest state in the
nation thank you so much may God bless
you
[Music]
[Applause]
The Joint convention will please stand
and be revent attentive of Pastor
Michael warley office of
benediction it is said that a
benediction is a uh short blessing of a
scripture that can be
challenging it can be
encouraging it can can be assuring but
it also can be a principle to live by so
as I offer of this prayer if you would
permit me I would love to read this
passage of scripture to your hearing
it's coming out of 2 Corinthians chapter
13:1 it reads finally
Brethren farewell become complete be of
good Comfort be of one mind live in
peace and the god of love and peace will
be with you you bow with me
father in The Mighty and matchless name
of your son Jesus Lord we thank you for
this great ceremony father for our new
leader Governor Kelly aot Lord I ask two
things as we close father as she and
every elected official Here Come
Together father to meet the needs of the
residents of this great state father I
ask that you would protect them both
spiritually and physically father as
they meet the needs of the residents of
this great state Lord I ask that you
would meet the needs that is in their
lives father secondly I lift up all of
law enforcement in the mighty name of
Jesus that go out to protect and serve
Lord the residents of this great state
protect them father I pray for their
families as they go out Lord and are
performing their duties that you would
give them comfort and peace as they Lord
would then return home and one other
thing Lord i' like to thank you for
governor senuna and his leadership oh
father now Lord as we leave this place
but never from your presence I ask that
the words of our mouths and the
meditations of all of our hearts will be
acceptable in your sight oh Lord our
Rock and Our Redeemer and if you agree
with that prayer please say with me amen
amen
please be seated while the governor
executive counselors and other
dignitaries are escorted from the
chamber
will all the guests um please uh depart
the chamber
C e
[Music]
you
the members of the House and Senate
please will all the members of the House
please be seated and remain seated we
still got a couple of things to
[Music]
do e
Senator join conven
right out of joint represent Osborne and
Senator BS will move at the Joint
convention arise are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos n the eyes have it the joint
convention is
adjourned than you as always house
members please remain
seated oh I know I know
[Music]
sorry the house will come to order the
chair recognized a member from Auburn
president
osbor for a motion to adjourn from the
early
session are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes haven't the motion is
adopted representative Osborne moves at
the house standing recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills vacate
motions and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppos n the eyes
have it the motion is adopted the house
is in reest to the call of the chair